il m'a toujours paru important d'aider
les gens dans le besoin
déjà lorsque j'étais au collège je me
suis rendu plusieurs fois à lourdes pour
accompagner les malades même si je ne
suis pas vraiment croyante
c'était des personnes âgées qui avaient
beaucoup de choses très intéressantes à
nous raconter et lorsqu il nous remercie
d'être là pour eux ça me faisait
toujours chaud aux quarts depuis
j'essaie de me rendre utile pour
retrouver cette sensation de partage qui
m'a porté tant de bonheur et pour ça
quoi de mieux qu'un voyage solidaire je
m'appelle camille criado et je suis ici
ce soir pour vous parler de mon voyage à
madagascar
je suis parti cet été avec une
association humanitaire de mon école
unired et sur place nous avons été
accueillis par notre association
partenaire à madière ce sont deux
associations qui oeuvrent pour la
protection de l'enfance
madagascar c'est un des pays les plus
pauvres au monde avec 80 % des malgaches
qui vit avec moins de deux dollars par
jour
lorsque je vous évoque madagascar vous
pensez à la chaleur à la vanille au
baobab aux lémuriens ou penser au film
mais lorsque j'ai parlé de mon voyage à
mes parents ce alors évoqué plus tôt ça
la pauvreté les maladies car il ya la
peste à madagascar ou encore les
agressions des touristes pour leur
argent
en fait ils avaient peur car c'était mon
premier voyage en dehors dehors de
l'europe et j'ai pas choisi la
destination de la plus touristique
mais justement je leur ai expliqué que
j'ai choisi ce voyage parce que j'avais
besoin de donner un sens à ce que je
faisais
sur place nous avons été très bien
accueillis les malgaches sont des gens
très chaleureux et nous avons d'abord
rencontré la nao et patrick c'est un
couple de malgaches qui font partie de
la matière et je me souviens de cette
phrase qui m'a beaucoup marqué que
patrick nous a dit patrick que vous
voyez ici en photo
il nous a dit les européens ont la
montre nous nous avons le temps et c'est
vrai que les manoeuvres ne sont pas très
regardants sur leurs il appelle sa mort
amoureux chez nous on pourrait traduire
sa part mollo mollo ou doucement pas
trop vite
par exemple si vous donnez rendez vous
un malgache à 14 heures il faudra pas
l'attendre avant 15 voire 16 heures il
l'aura pas perdu son temps et leur a
simplement fait autre chose
en fait c'est ça peu importe ce que font
les malgaches ils n'ont pas le sentiment
de perdre leur temps tandis que chez
nous en france et en europe en général
ce qu'on fait de chaque minute de notre
temps est scrupuleusement planifiée ça
ne vous est jamais arrivé de
culpabiliser et prévoir fait une sieste
ou après avoir regardé un épisode dans
trop de votre série et c'est comme ça
que notre voyage a débuté par notre
rencontre avec la batterie nous nous
sommes ensuite rendu sur trois d'amadea
pour y apporter notre soutien
sur les deux premiers sites nous avons
apporté un soutien plutôt à leur
développement économique et sur le
troisième site
on était plus présent sur le plan social
le premier site c'est une coopérative
une sécherie dans laquelle ils sèchent
des fruits comme des ananas ou des
physalies ce que vous connaissez
peut-être sous le nom de l'amour en cage
nous sur place nous avons appris une
partie de l'équipe à fabriquer des pâtes
de fruits ça permet de gâcher moins de
fruits car sous forme de pâte de fruit
ça se conserve plus longtemps et
aujourd'hui ils fabriquent plus ils
vendent ces pâtes de fruits c'était
notre objectif et nous en sommes fiers
vous connaissez peut-être le proverbe
selon lequel lorsqu'on donne un poisson
à un homme
un jour on le nourrit pour un jour mais
lorsqu'on lui apprend empêcher le
nourrit pour toujours et c'est l'idée
que nous avons suivi en apprenant
malgaches à fabriquer des pâtes de
fruits on voulait les aider sur le long
terme et sur place nous vivions avec les
malgaches et par conséquent on a eu
beaucoup d'occasions de discuter avec
eux des choses passionnantes
on a comparé nos cultures nos traditions
ils nous ont parlé du droit des femmes
dans leur pays ou encore de leurs
rituels mortuaire et pour moi ce sont
tous ces moments qui font la richesse
d'un voyage ensuite sur le deuxième site
ils font de la sériciculture
c'est-à-dire qu'ils élèvent des vers à
soie puis il file et tisse le fil
jusqu'à obtenir des écharpes en soie
nous nous avons fabre finement financé
par dont la construction d'un nouveau
bâtiment pour qu'il puisse l'espace et
leurs machines et gagnait gagneront en
efficacité
travailler dans de meilleures conditions
on devait aussi d aider à fabriquer ces
bâtiments mais mucha mourra lorsqu'on
arrivait sur place
les bières n'avait pas commencé à être
livrée n'a donc pas pu les aider
cette pierre la construction
pardon
pour le côté social et pour la petite
anecdote à côté de sociétés situées un
petit village dans laquelle vivaient une
grand-mère et de nombreux enfants
celui là chez vous voyez juste au dessus
et plus tard nous avons appris que cette
grand mère et la grand-mère de tout le
village car elle avait une quinzaine
d'enfants etc les enfants avaient une
des enfants qu'elle avait une
descendance et cela m'a interpellé car
ça m'a donné l'impression que les
malgaches vivaient dans l'ancien temps
mais malgré ce décalage il était heureux
et ça m'a donné à réfléchir sur le mode
de vie ou sur le sens de la vie enfin le
dernier site sur lequel nous nous sommes
rendu est un orphelinat
sur place ils vivent des enfants dont
les parents n'ont pas les moyens de
s'occuper ou des enfants qui n'ont pas
de parents simplement illégalement des
mamans qui apportent leurs bébés tous
les jours à l'association pour que les
associations donnent à manger aux
enfants alors que lorsqu'elles n'ont pas
les moyens de le faire elle même
on en a profité pour donner des conseils
de nutrition et des notions d'hygiène à
ses enfants et avec les enfants nous
avons nous avons joué avec eux à
l'orphelinat avec tous les enfants de
l'école on les a accompagnés sur la
plage à la messe c'était des super
moments et les enfants savaient que nous
n'étions pas là pour longtemps et que
nous allions repartir ils ont l'habitude
des associations qui viennent les voir
et par conséquent ils savent profiter
simplement de ces moments sans se
soucier de ce qui va se passer après il
avait des sourires sincères qui qui me
faisait chaud au coeur et qui me
rappelait les malades que j'accompagnais
à lourdes
ce que j'ai retenu de mon voyage à
madagascar c'est que donner du sens à ce
qu'on fait c'est primordial ici pour
nous l'idée était avant tout
d'accompagner les malades les malgaches
dans leur développement au lieu de
simplement leur apporter des vêtements
de la nourriture ou de l'argent ce qu'on
a fait mais ce n'était pas l'objectif
principal et cela a complètement
bouleversé notre vision du voyage
d'un côté comme de l'autre on a beaucoup
appris
on a vraiment pu voir ainsi que donner
sait recevoir
on a vécu des moments magiques parmi les
malgaches on ne se connaissait pas
vraiment important jeu
encore ému ce soir en repensant à la
sonnerie qu'ils organisaient pour nos
adieux c'est une soirée karaoké à
laquelle on avait chanté tour à tour en
français puis en malgache est ensemble
et c'était beau les malgaches qui l'ont
fait grandir car grâce à eux nous avons
redécouvert la valeur du temps avec mon
amour à baisser la valeur de l'eau car
pour nos deux chez nous n'avions qu'un
seau d'eau chaude pour deux donc on a
vite réalisé les économies d'eau
possible sur une douche
d'ailleurs sur un des sites il n'y avait
pas d'eau courante
donc on devait en éviter au maximum ont
gâché car il fallait le haut puis pour
s'en procurer
ou alors on en prenait dans l'abreuvoir
qui servait à pour la chasse d'eau des
toilettes
il ya d'ailleurs même pour boire les
malgaches n'utilise pas forcément de
deux bouteilles
il vous ils prennent l'eau du riz l'eau
dans laquelle ils ont cuisiné le riz
puis je la vois ça un goût de te fumer
c'est particulier on peu précis et après
cette belle expérience
je ne peux que vous conseiller de donner
de votre temps pour faire le bonheur des
autres
car ça contribuera votre propre bonheur
il n'y a rien qui fasse plus chaud au
coeur que les sourires c'est une
personne à qui vous avez apporté votre
aide pour terminer je vous propose de
nous quitter sur ces quelques images des
magnifiques paysages de madagascar
[Applaudissements]